foreign
[Music]
scientific thank you for joining today's
webinar real-time PCR for the molecular
detection and research of infectious
disease pathogens Beyond SARS cov2
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click Send we'll answer as many
questions as as we have time for at the
end of the presentation you may also
submit any technical issues here as well
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation we have two great
speakers today from Thermo Fisher
Scientific Celeste stone is senior
manager of Business Development she has
been supporting the infectious disease
in pharmacogenomics molecular Testing
Research portfolios for the past decade
Celeste has a Bachelor's of Science in
biology and anthropology and a masters
in teaching biology from the University
of Pittsburgh
we also have Jorge Fonseca he holds a
degree in mechanical engineering from
MIT and an MBA from the University of
Massachusetts Amherst Jorge started
started his career in r d where he was
involved in the development of real-time
PCR products he has since moved into
product management he's covered research
agrogenomics and clinical research
applications
currently he leads a team responsible
for molecular Testing Research Solutions
spanning infectious diseases oncology
and pharmacogenomics
we have a great agenda today the
35-minute presentation will be divided
into four sections first Celeste will
cover infectious disease detection and
research methods and the benefits
associated with molecular testing
she will turn it over to Jorge to
discuss the critical quality and
performance parameters implemented for
as they design and Manufacturing
followed by an overview of molecular
testing workflows including the ability
to Scale based on instrument and format
options
and then Celeste will finish the webinar
by exploring how to expand your
infectious disease research and testing
menu
so I'd like to hand over the webinar to
Celeste
thank you Trisha for the introduction
and thank you all for joining us today
if you are a current customer familiar
with our products and support we greatly
appreciate your partnership over the
years we hope we can continue to support
your success
many of you have come to trust and rely
on us due to our intense commitment
during the pandemic to create a test
that was robust not only in performance
but also in Supply
for those of you we haven't had the
opportunity to work with yet a quick bit
of background on that very impactful
year for the laboratory
during the height of the pandemic over
50 percent of the testing utilized our
technology either our instruments or
reagents we have helped our amazing
customers collectively perform over 700
million tests to date
and what was most impactful during that
during that time and also very stressful
was our ability to scale our production
to secure supply chain and meet Global
testing demand
it was no easy feat and I'm very proud
of my colleagues around the globe who
contribute to that level of passion and
hard work
prior to the pandemic we built a
portfolio that could service our
customers from end to end instruments
reagents software service and support
we were able to leverage that Foundation
throughout the pandemic and now we want
to continue post pandemic to be a
complete and trusted resource for our
customers
so if we hadn't had the chance to be a
service to your laboratory yet we'd love
to hear from you
so what's next for your lab
we've made it through the pandemic years
of high demand Cova testing of course
Cova testing will continue to be crucial
but will you maintain your current
testing strategy or will you explore
things like pooling as infection rates
decrease or where you look at other
sample types such as saliva or remote
rapid PCR detections be a need
moreover as we shift into fall and flu
season we need to explore a broader
respiratory menu keep in mind we have
our coveted flu eua as well as
panel-based respiratory options which
will which I'll get more into later
when you think what's next and begin
that exploratory process whether it's
infectious disease inherited disease
oncology pharmacogenomics we'd love to
join you on that Journey
and within that journey I do want to
recognize the challenges you face each
day
from how to maintain profits and revenue
streams within an ever-changing
landscape to Staffing challenges and
shortages technology technology advances
to keep up with competition with other
labs
clearly supportive address these
challenges is needed and your ability to
continue to operate in be of service is
crucial
and to that point
let's take a look at the impact
infectious diseases have globally
6.8 million doctor visits per year 15 of
all Health Care expenditures and they
kill 250 000 to half a million people
each year with costs between 71 billion
to 167 billion annually
there is a clear need for fast low-cost
detection solutions to improve care and
reduce Health Care expenditures
now taking a look more granularly by top
infectious diseases that impact our
world respiratory tract infections
leading cause of Burden worldwide with
viruses such as the common cold and flu
leading the way but it is a bacterial
infections that tend to cause more
severity namely pneumonia and
tuberculosis and of course testing speed
and sensitivity is crucial and that's
why implementing qpcr based tests is so
favorable
looking at other tests that could also
benefit from this approach urinary tract
infections they are among the most
prevalent diseases globally resulting in
approximately 150 million deaths a year
challenges such as high recurrence and
antimicrobial resistance threaten to
increase that burden and when you
consider the limitations with test
current testing methodologies culture
for example can take days and fastidious
organisms or polymicrobial infections
resistance resistant to culture pose a
challenge
a multiplex qpcr approach can
significantly decrease turnaround time
while being highly sensitive and
specific
while UTIs threatened the elderly
population more than other demographics
GI infections are the second most common
of infections worldwide and can be
deadly among infants and children
and unlike UTI is not only are bacteria
significantly impactful but also viruses
and parasites again a qpcr method can
address testing all of these types of
organisms simultaneously versus
employing multiple testing methodologies
such as culture microscopy and
aminoassays
moving on to another area of infectious
disease testing that is very crucial for
the female population vaginal infections
when a healthy vaginal microbiota is
disrupted and other overgrowth of
pathogenic organisms
in the Flora can cause infection such as
bacterial vaginosis candidiasis
trichomoniasis and higher risk for
sexually transmitted infections
bacterial vaginosis is quite prevalent
up to 29 prevalence globally which
translates into a global economic burden
of 4.8 billion
when we add the impact and burden of
STIs considering this number keeps
climbing year over year and it can
result in life-threatening complications
we know early detection is crucial for
both vaginal infections and STIs
again traditional methods culture
antigen-based tests serology they all
fall short of the speed sensitivity and
specificity molecular methods offer all
in one Standalone test
to sum up infectious disease testing is
an arguably very crucial globally but
there are challenges with each of the
traditional methodologies when we
consider culture it is specific only to
the bacterial targets and can have
limitations when dealing with fastidious
organisms or instances of a
polymicrobial infection moreover results
take days
with my cross weight methods we are
considering subjectivity concerns and
lack of trained microscopists there are
also challenges with other molecular
tests that have fixed content that lack
flexibility or the ability to add new
pathogens of concern quickly
for these reasons we are indeed seeing a
rise in demand for molecular testing
methodologies as they can afford within
one test speed specificity insensitivity
without the challenges of multiple
traditional methodologies
key qualities of a successful molecular
diagnostic tests include analytical and
clinical validity qpcr is considered a
gold standard and has become the most
popular molecular diagnostic choice for
many clinical applications
two other key qualities in of immense
importance are clinical and economic
utility we talked about the need for
faster more encompassing testing in a
single method to help ease the demand in
economic burden in a molecular
diagnostic approach can help address
this need
and with that I'll pass it on to Jorge
to further discuss critical quality in
performance parameters
thank you Celeste indeed so having heard
from Celeste uh the importance of these
applications and the need for
development of assays let's talk about
the parameters uh and processes that are
used and implemented by Therma Fisher
towards that purpose so how do we go
around developing and putting together
this uh PCR based research solutions for
infectious diseases so it starts with
the content the assay selection our team
gathers identifies and gathers pathogen
assays for the most common infectious
diseases especially those that would
really benefit from molecular testing in
doing so we leverage information from
literature information from Key opinion
leaders and feedback and input from our
customers who are subject matter experts
in these we take that information and we
use it together with our r d and
bioinformatics teams to develop expanded
content panels in a variety of formats
that you'll see in the following slides
and we do that with the focus of having
the highest number of pathogen targets
available in the finished product we
take those assays that we have designed
and then we integrate them and optimize
them as part of an end-to-end workflow
solution so that includes optimizing and
integrating the sample preparation the
extraction and the reporting options to
complete this workflow solution
and the end result is we are then able
to launch flexible content real-time PCR
solutions for a variety of panels
spanning syndromic fixed content and
focus disease panels for infectious
disease research areas of which we'll
talk later on in this presentation
having talked about how uh the Journey
of the design process starts with the
assay we of course want to know about
the technology and chemistry that
enables the performance of those assays
for us that is the well-known and
Industry accepted tacman chemistry which
is validated by hundreds of patents and
Publications
the key step in the development of our
assays is our well-developed and
validated bioinformatics pipeline for
the development of primer and probe
sequences that tool has been optimized
through years and production of millions
of assays in our catalog and
manufacturing of tens of millions of of
assays that we ship to our customers
years after year
the pipeline integrates the
manufacturing data of those assays and
uses that to optimize the design of
future assays as a result our tacman
assays shine in the four areas of
specificity sensitivity reproducibility
and performance
on the area of specificity our Advanced
primary and probe sequence selection
criteria through the bioinformatics
pipeline together with the MGB probe
chemistry improve the performance in the
areas of specificity and reproducibility
knowing that the amplification is coming
from the intended target and not from
non-specific die binding on the audio
sensitivity the non-fluorescent quencher
on the tacman probes minimizes the
background signal and together with the
primer and probe design
maximizes the amplification of
efficiency which gives you better
sensitivity and accuracy which is
important and enables you to detect
targets at 10 or fewer copies in your
samples and in the reproducibility we
are able through our manufacturing
process and Quality Control process to
deliver deliver reproducible results
across various wells in your plate
across various tests in your run and
across various lots of the product and
of course we stand behind the
performance of this assays if they did
not perform as promised we will replace
or refund them
so having had having talked about the
attack man assay chemistry let's talk
about the specific kind of PCR run which
is most used in these applications with
this gene expression so as you know
reproducibility and the robustness of
the amplification are essential when
evaluating the performance of gene
expression and as you can see here we
deliver on both fronts you can see the
graph on the left demonstrates a lot to
lot consistency of our tacman gene
expression assays as evidenced by the
low Delta CT variation and on the right
you can see the effect the efficient
amplification which is center around 100
percent
so now let's talk about the workflows
let's talk about how you can use these
Technologies to develop end-to-end
workflows for the various applications
that uh Celeste discussed and how you
can choose the right products to meet
your needs depending on your throughput
so let's first look at this family of
instruments on our quad Studio qpcr
portfolio and you can see it spans a
variety of instruments we'll go into a
little bit more detail on the next slide
I'll just highlight here then they go
from lower throughput instruments with
fixed block systems that are better
suited for plates all the way through
medium throughput systems with
interchangeable blocks that can accept a
variety of consumable formats and all
the way through high through but uh for
specific formats which we'll talk about
in the next slides and as you can see
from the graphic the vast majority of
these instruments are cloud enabled and
several of them are automation ready
so let's discuss some of the details of
the instruments available in our
portfolio so starting at the lower
throughput end with the quantity 05
system this is a flock fixed block
system that is compatible with tacman
array plates be it 96 or 384 well blocks
and as you can see it's better better
suited for low to medium uh throughput
testing Labs going up and throughput we
have our quantity 07 flex and quantity 7
Pro systems which are compatible with
tech matter rate plates both 96 and 34
well as well as our microfluidic
attackment array cards which are for 384
reactions and which we'll talk about in
a later slide and then moving up in
throughput we have our most flexible and
higher throughput system the quantity of
12K which is compatible with all the uh
previously mentioned consumables as well
as the open array plate are highest
throughput consumable which we'll see in
the next slides
having spoken about the instruments
let's look at the matching consumables
that complete those workflows so once
again a range from lower throughput to
higher throughput we start with a
familiar attack man array plates on the
96 well format
which offer reaction volumes of 10 to 20
microliters per well and are better
suited for lower to medium throughput
applications going up in throughput we
have our 384 uh well assay formats at 10
microliters per reaction volume and then
moving on to the microfluidic formats we
have the tacman array cards uh those
I'll bring the reaction volume down to
one microliter and offer 384 reactions
and on the highest end we have the
tacman open array plates
which have only 33 nanoliter reaction
volumes and we'll talk about the
specifics of each of these formats in
future slides but it's important to know
and the tacman assays that we discussed
in previous slides can be made available
pre-spotted in various configurations
and in each of these formats depending
on your needs
so let's talk about the first format the
tacman array plates uh these are the
familiar 96 and 34 well formats the good
news here is that you can select
whatever content you want from our
kakman assay menu and we can have those
pre-spotted and conveniently dried down
in in the plate formats prior to
delivery eliminating the need to pipette
the content upon receiver your lab these
are optimal for low to medium throughput
lab solutions they require low sample
input of only five microliters per
reaction and are compatible with the
quad Studio
instruments that we saw in the previous
slide
so what is the workflow uh that you
would use with attack on right plates
it's a very familiar workflow so as you
see you would start by receiving your
samples uh the workflows would be
compatible with a variety of sample
types including urine swabs or
nasopharyngeal samples the sample
preparation can utilize our Thermo
fissure
Kingfisher flux purification system as
well as our applied biosystems magma
kits which enable up to 96 samples per
run with a semi-automated workflow and
then the real-time PCR happens in the
quantity of family instruments that we
reviewed in the previous slides to
complete the workflow we have various
options for analysis and report as well
as compatibility with third-party tools
that you may use for interpretation of
your data
so going up in throughput and talking
about the tacman array cards for those
of you that are not familiar with this
uh consumer format they have the same
footprint as a 96 or 384 well plate they
are plastic consumables with the foil
backing but they are a microfluidic uh
reaction volume uh consumable with 384
reaction sites as you can see so the way
this works and we'll look at the
workflow in the next slide is uh the
user is able to buy pet eight samples
into the eight Wells or lanes that you
see on the screen there's a process in
which the sample is distributed to the
reaction sites without any risk of
contamination and without the need for
complex robotics or automation that
minimizes uh the sample the Hands-On
time to only 10 minutes to add the
sample and master mix and because of the
low volumes utilized it's a very cost of
effective approach that minimizes your
reagent usage as seen in the previous
slides in this particular format is
compatible with the quantity 07 family
as well as the quantity of 12K family of
instruments with the dedicated blocks
in terms of the workflow as you can
imagine it's similar to the one we
reviewed for the tacman array plates the
only difference here is in the sample
loading so I talked about the first part
of the process easily loading the sample
with a pipette into each one of the
eight Lanes without risk of
contamination and with very low Hands-On
type Hands-On time after that there is a
ceiling step with an including tool it's
a very quick manual process and the
loaded cards are spun in a centrifuge to
distribute the samples that entire
process requires less than 10 minutes
and on hands on time the entire workflow
has a turnaround time of three hours to
first results and five hours totals per
run and of course our technical support
teams are available throughout the
process to help with any questions that
you may have
foreign
plate consumer format uh which is our
highest throughput format for those of
you who are not familiar with an open
array it's the size of a microscope
slide made of metal very thin and
populated with over 3 000 through holes
so they do not have a bottom like
traditional wells in our proprietary
manufacturing process we apply a
hydrophilic coating to the inside of the
through holes on a hydrophobic coating
to the external surfaces that has the
end result of allowing us to perform
individual qpcr reactions in each of the
3072 through Holes without risk of
contamination with neighboring reactions
and as you can see in the slide you have
great flexibility in how you can use
those reaction sites from maximizing
your panel size across fewer samples to
selecting a smaller panel content and
maximizing the sample throughput in your
test testing and the platform is
available for supporting both genotyping
and gene expression applications in
terms of the throughput each
quantitative run can run four open array
plates at a time for over 12 000
reactions at a time
and in terms of the time it takes to
generate the results you can either run
12 to 16 open array plates per day
depending on your shift structure which
translates to 35
000 to 45
000 total reactions in a day it's a very
fast uh bench to work benchtop workflow
with minimal Hands-On time all that is
required from the user in the lab is to
load the samples on mastermix and the
workflow that we'll see in the next
slide and that can be done in as little
as 20 minutes and due to the 333
nanoliter reaction volume uh there's a
high efficiency of reagent usage and
cost savings that comes available with
that
so let's talk about the workflow for the
open array plates as you can see there's
a trend here the workflows are familiar
and there's minimal change from one
platform to the other in this case uh
the change from the previous formats is
on how the samples are loaded on the
open array plate uh there is an uh
system dedicated for this step is called
the open array accufill system very
convenient workflow all you have to do
is Place uh your uh 384 well plate with
your desired samples select the
configuration hit go and the robot will
automatically deposit those samples onto
the open array plate and provide the
information onto the placement of those
samples for use in the workflow steps of
your analysis and then that moves on to
the quantitative K which as we mentioned
can run four arrays at a time with a two
to four hour cycle time depending on the
application
so wrapping up let's look at how these
consumable formats that we've discussed
uh compare with respect to throughput
and what advantage they offer so we
start with the lowest throughput single
tubes that we are all familiar with
um those are available as inventory
products and give you the highest
flexibility for the lowest throughput in
terms of the consumable formats that
we've discussed today we have of course
attachment rate plates available in both
96 and 284 well formats offering the
convenience of pre-spotted asset content
and they run on the instruments that
support automation are on our ideal for
medium throughput moving on to the
tacman array cards those support 384
microfloaded reactions as we mentioned
also offering the convenience of free
spotted assays while minimizing the risk
of contamination and simplifying your
Hands-On workflow they offer great
convenience and cost savings without the
need for complex Robotics and on the
highest end of the throughput scale
there are of course the open array
throughput open array plates as we
mentioned which offer over 12 000
reactions for instrument run that is the
highest throughput for qpcr Solutions
which is ideal for High throughput
research applications or large projects
in terms of the flavors of products that
are available for each of these all of
the plate formats technology plates
cards and open array plates are in
offering are offered in both inventory
and custom content
and now I will pass it back on to
Celeste
thank you Jorge for that review of our
instruments and formats
continuing into the last section of our
discussion today I'd like to highlight
our offering for infectious disease
we have several inventory panel options
available from respiratory with our
broad panel of viral bacterial and
fungal targets compatible with multiple
sample input types in Broad strain
coverage to UTI which enables increased
accuracy of urinary tract pathogens
quick turnaround time and overall better
sensitivity compared to culture
for vaginal testing we offer a
comprehensive panel that incorporates
bacterial vaginosis candidiasis aerobic
vaginitis and STIs
and as Jorge touched upon these assays
have all demonstrated to be highly
accurate with reproducible performance
and are compatible with different sample
input types as well
I also want to mention we will soon have
officially launched a comprehensive GI
panel and we offer Customs for wound
nail and resistance Gene testing
if the inventory solution doesn't meet
your needs all of our content is
available in flexible formats as Jorge
reviewed or customizable by content
plus we offer support which I'll touch
upon more in a following slide
I thought it made sense given the global
impact that antibiotic resistance is
having and the need for antimicrobial
stewardship to highlight our offering
for antibiotic resistance Gene assays we
know resistance genes can be shared
between bacteria through horizontal Gene
transfer and resistance genes within
pathogenic organisms is a growing threat
to Public Health rendering once
effective antibiotic treatments
ineffective
we offer the option to complement any
panel with our antibiotic resistance
genes or they can be ordered as single
tubes highlighted at the bottom are
common ABR genes of interest that we
offer and keep in mind you can also
create your own custom assay if we don't
have your Gene of Interest
so as you can see we have all the
content and flexibility but what about
support I want to highlight our
analytical validation Services which is
so valuable valuable when there is a
learning curve or when time is critical
purchasing an AV a Ford UA project
manager and an on-site dedicated FAS to
help verify assay performance parameters
we will help you develop and optimize
your validation workflow Supply controls
as well as analysis support and template
documentation
our goal is to streamline the validation
process and save you time we know your
time is valuable
so wrapping up here everyone and again
thank you so much for joining us we hope
this has been informative for you if
there is one takeaway from this
discussion today it's that we pride
ourselves on what we bring to the table
for molecular detection of infectious
disease pathogens
and we strive to be as trusted partner
supporting your journey in the lab we
believe our instruments and formats
provide flexibility into the future as
lab needs change and that our expansive
Network and Industry knowledge make us a
partner you know you can trust to meet
your evolving needs and with that thanks
again for joining us please do not
hesitate to reach out and let us know
how we can best support you we love
hearing from you
thank you Celeste thank you Jorge for
your presentations today we did have a
number of questions come in so
um I'm gonna try to ask you these
questions and some sort of
uh meaningful order so we're not jumping
back and forth too much
um
first one I see is about
false positive
positive the question is I'm concerned
about false positives with a molecular
approach versus culture
um can you speak about the challenge in
dealing with false positives and
possible cross-reactivity within a
sample
I don't know Celeste do you want to take
that one
sure and it's a great question uh and
this is exactly why we offer validation
Services it is necessary to establish a
limit of detection to demonstrate
reproducibility and establish cutoff
criteria for accurately making those
positive calls regarding
cross-reactivity as part of the
validation process you will also perform
exclusivity testing in order to
understand the assay limitations in how
to properly interpret your data
I hope that addresses the the question
there but please feel free to reach out
if you want to further discuss
no
um here's another one
um when you are dealing with commensal
organisms on a panel how can I be sure
that I'm making the proper decision to
characterize a sample
it's either pathogenic or infectious
I'm happy to take that one again Trisha
it's kind of a bit of a similar vein and
again it's a really good question and I
will point back again to validation it
will allow you to look at this negative
and positive sample types in order just
to establish that proper call criteria
okay
um I'm gonna ask I think this one would
be for Jorge and I think you mentioned
this during your talk a little bit but
can you tell us a little bit more about
how Thermo Fisher determines what
pathogens
or you know
to put on their panels
um even designing the specific targets
to the different pathogens can you tell
us a little bit more about that
yes of course I I think it's another
great question and you're right I
alluded to it a little bit in the
presentation so it starts at the early
stages with our bioinformatics and our
new teams reviewing the literature in
terms of what's uh most relevant to the
applications we also work with key
opinion leaders who are subject matter
experts in this area take their input
and of course as we advance a little
further in the project we work with
Early Access customers who have
experience in these areas and are
developing this panel so it's a
iterative process but we feel confident
that at the end we do end up with a
highly relevant selection of pathogen
targets and the corresponding assays
but I believe on the thermal Fisher
website there's a tool that folks can
use to look up
um pathogens targets Etc to see what
might work best for them
um depending on whether they want to buy
a panel or you know design something on
their own
that that is correct Trisha that's a
great call out uh yeah so if you go to
our website uh there's a dedicated
search experience specifically for
microbial detection assays so you can
look uh for assays that are available at
the Target level or even at the strain
level and for uh the results that you
receive you will not just get one result
so you'll see everything that's relevant
if you make a broad search you'll get a
broad list of results and there are
multiple uh features and functionalities
that allow you to dive into the details
of each assay and determine the one
that's best for your specific need
okay okay
so that's great for customers who are
thinking maybe about designing their own
panel
indeed persons versus more of the
off-the-shelf products that are
available okay that's great can you talk
a little bit about the platform itself
do you um the question says do these
platforms require sample batching
uh yes uh uh a basic point I should have
mentioned uh yeah so
um as you saw from the presentation we
have a variety of instruments that are
suitable for different throughput levels
and a variety of consumers that also
match that spectrum of throughput so
what we found uh is the experience of
our customers is that we are uniquely
positioned to help them maximize the
efficiency of their operations through
the batching element of our platforms
while being able to tailor their
solution to the throughput that they
have so no uh they do require batching
but because we offer that flexibility of
workflows the lab can tailor their
selection to the throughput so that they
don't they're able to maximize the
efficiency without uh you know
sacrificing uh the throughput need
okay
I think this one might be a good one
first the last
um
your products are research use only but
as a clinical lab with minimal ldt
experience what support or guidance can
you provide for me
that is correct our products are
research use only but as mentioned we
can provide analytical validation
support and while the clinical
validation would be the laboratory's
responsibility there are certainly
third-party resources that could assist
you through the clinical evaluation
um okay we have time for one more
question
um question is I'm a region impacted by
the new multi-x LCD
what Guidance Do you have for a lab
going through the technical assessment
um approval process
maybe Celeste would you like to take
that one
sure yeah happy too um I I do understand
that your CLIA validated test has to go
through additional validations according
to the new mod x guidelines I recommend
going directly to Modi X for your
questions they have a dedicated email
for this purpose if you're not getting
your questions fully answered via email
perhaps you can schedule a meeting with
them to further understand their
expectations if there are particular
challenges you are facing in order to
complete your technical assessment in
including the additional validation work
there are third party resources who may
be able to further assist you through
that process
foreign
thank you
so I just want to say thank you again to
our speakers Celeste and Jorge for your
time today and your important research
um and supporting this portfolio we
would also like to thank lab roots for
hosting us today
um Thermo Fisher has been the sponsor
for today's webcast
um before we go I want to thank the
audience as well for joining and all the
interesting questions
um questions questions we didn't have
time to address today
um and those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speakers by the contact information
you provided at the time for
registration
and this webcast will be viewed and
available on demand
um lab routes will alert you via email
when it's available for replay
um we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event and anyone interested
in learning more about these products
again
um
uh thermal fissure scientific
Representatives would be happy to to
sleep with you
so um thanks again and hope to see you
all soon goodbye